[Music]
we're going to get started with the last
talk in this section
by henrik bankston about future
simple async parallel and distributed
processing in
r what's next hi everyone
my name is henrik i work at ucsf here in
cal
in san francisco
but i first want to say that i'm super
honest to be mentioned in the same
sentence as steve
about the for each project so thank you
very much
so i am a trained computer scientist
and i did a phd in mathematical
statistics and i'm doing very applied
work
and mostly in cancer genomics and we
process a lot of large data sets
and when i've been large i and i prefer
to do things from r
and by large we're talking terabytes and
sometimes 100 terabytes
so r is the glue for me
so what do we mean by parallel
processing so the most common use case
is
we want things to finish sooner so if we
run it sequentially it's going to finish
tomorrow
but if we can paralyze it's finished
today and we typically go to our local
computer and say
i'm going to use my different cores here
distributed computing is basically you
want to reach out to
more machines and paralyze over those
and i do want to mention that
synchronous
programming and processing it's related
to parallel processing in the most
common use case that people might know
here is
if you have a shiny application and
there is a button and you click on that
button
and that needs to run a lot of
computation it would take a long time
before it's finished
you don't want your user interface to
freeze up so you want to run that in the
background in parallel
and the future framework supports these
needs so
we got a brilliant introduction to
parallel processing in our already
i'm going to repeat a little bit but
if you as a developer want to start you
have sequential code and you want to go
parallel processing you want it just to
be simple
it shouldn't like bother your
development so let's consider this
simple case
we have a vector of 20 elements and
you want to call a function called slow
on each of the elements
and what happens inside there is that r
will basically
step by step go through them and if slow
takes one minute to finish each time
it's going to take 20 minutes and with
the parallel package we have
the beautiful mcl apply we heard in
several
talks now and it looks very similar so
as a developer it feels familiar
the only difference here you need to
specify how many cars you want to
paralyze
so if you're paralyzed on two cars
what's going to happen inside the
the data the x is going to split up in
two chunks
and workers will be started and they
will start
working on this down the stream and
since they're two working in the same
task it's going to finish sooner
about 10 minutes so everything is done
and everything is beautiful and as we
heard
if you do this you might say oops you
discover it
did not work on windows
and there are other cases where you
should not use the
forking property of mcl apply
so you'd start exploring other things so
in the parallel package we also have the
parallel apply in the family of that
which is background our sessions running
and they work on all machines on all
operating systems for each is the
big player here there are others if
you're biconductor you have other things
so you start thinking which one should i
pick here
another thing is like what operating
system should i support today i only
need linux
but maybe next year someone will ask to
support windows
or you get collaborators on windows or
mac so you start thinking about that
on day one when you start you don't want
to think about these things but you have
to
will it scale it runs on my local
machine
what if we get 96 cores will it work
will it work on five machines and so on
and do i need to maintain several code
bases we already saw that example in the
previous talk where
typically people have sequential code
and
by adding support for parallel code it's
very common to say
if not parallel run the sequential or
run some parallel version of it so now
you have two code bases
you have to maintain you have to figure
out test coverage for those
and twice the risk for bugs basically
so questions like this you have and then
when you tried everything you might
actually end up and
everything works for you and then there
is some user it didn't work for me
because some global variable wasn't
handled so that's
where the future framework in the future
package comes in
it's try to take away all those things
you don't have to worry about them
it's the it's a simple unifying solution
for parallel
apis in our the motto is
right once run anywhere 100 cross
platform is installed
super easily in all packages you don't
have to worry about that
as i claim it's very well tested got
lots of cpu mileage and used in
production
and it's meant to be so
things just work there will be corner
cases
but that they can be fixed but most
of the time it will just work
so i need to tell you a little bit about
the core of this
so if you peek into mcl apply power
apply for each and a lot of other
solutions
they have in principle three things in
common
three building blocks and we pulled out
those
concepts into the future package so one
is
you have an r expression and you want to
run that in parallel
so there's a function in the package
future called future
that you say take this expression run it
in parallel and
keep the track of it in the handle
and then you can go to that thing in the
background
and say are you done you call result
done true false true false
and depending on the answer in your code
you can do different things
and of course in the end of the day you
want the value from this expression to
come back to you
so that's a function called value and if
it's not done yet it will wait till it's
done
so these three constructs are very
powerful and i didn't invent them
this came up in the mid 70s by different
groups
and it's been studying computer science
and that's
that's where the term future was coined
um so with these things we can now build
our first
parallel l apply and this code
works it shows the gist of the idea
the real thing you want to do a little
bit more bells and whistles
beneath the hood but it works so the
idea here is like
instead of trying to see this instead of
calling this
function on each element as is in your
current session you just spawn it off
as a future in parallel so you get like
a list of futures here handles to those
and then in the end of your function you
say give me the values of this because
that's what i'm interested in in return
and what happens behind the scenes the
workers will like start working on the
futures when they're available
and this runs in parallel
so these are very powerful building
blocks i say
and it allows you if you want to intro
do parallel processing your practice to
stay with your coding style so if you
like base r
l apply there is the future dot apply
package
that provides future hell apply future
apply and all different styles there and
they work the same
so you basically just have to prepend
your package with future underscore
and then magic happens um
if you like tidal verse and use per the
per map function
davis created a fur package with the
same idea prepend with future underscore
and it would just work
and if you like for each if you used it
before
or you want to use that api style
there is the do future adapter to for
each which
brings you all of the future framework
and options into for each
framework so you can stick with whatever
you like here
and other people would invent other apis
for this too
in the future so to speak
okay so i didn't mention how you specify
number of course and stuff
and in the same idea of for each
that is not your decision as a developer
to decide
that is something the user should decide
because you can never predict
what the current users or the future
users will have as
computational resources and
some user might want to run your code in
sequential and they just call a function
called plan sequential and they
get that setting and this is actually
the default
they might want to run it in parallel on
a local machine they can specify how
many cores they want to use all cores by
default
someone have a local machine a
machine in another university or and
at the same time they might have
something in the cloud and they can
specify this and they paralyze out the
work on this
or if you have a high performance
compute cluster
you can use a slurm job schedule for
instance
and use that as to paralyze but key
thing here
as a developer your change will your
code will look exactly the same all the
time so you don't have to worry about
this
so i've been saying is worry free worry
less
does it work um
yes no no but it's
so don't take my word on it it's been on
sorry
it's been on grant since 2015 but the
code is older
there are some adapters at adoptions
here
excuse me someone has to cut this out
so drake for instance it's a
workflow manager in r it's similar to
like a unix make
with bells and whistles in r it can use
parallelization with futures underneath
shiny if you use a synchronous shiny at
the very bottom
you can use futures to achieve that
and from testing perspective is
is a lot of testing all platforms
possible
all new versions of our uh running of
course reverse dependency checks and now
more than 100 packages
that's the immediate dependencies
another thing
because of the for each success there
are
six or 700 packages on cran that use for
each
player carat glm net etc
and i found a way to a lot of them have
really good examples
so i tweaked the example code to force
them to run in parallel
and with futures that allows me to test
futures
in all these real use cases and they
pass so that's a validation for futures
and there is also a future.test package
so if anyone comes and want to
write a new backend for parallel
processing they can use this
validation suite of validation tests to
make sure they conform to the future
standard
and that's a nice contract because as a
developer you don't have to worry about
testing on all possible future back-ends
because that's taking care of it's in
user two you know
when i pick up a certified backend it
will work
okay so
i hope i convince you to try it out if
you're curious
so what's new so in 2019
finally design wrapped up
this thing about output messages warning
errors
so error has been handled from early
days but people been asking about
warnings and output and we heard that
today
and if you look at a
this toy example here it's not very
efficient but you have a vector of -1 10
and 30 and you want to call take the log
of those you can use that in an
l apply call and in each iteration
you say which element you operate on as
well you're going to get the output
z equal minus 1 10 and 30. we're also
going to get a warning
because that log minus one is not
defined
okay so if we try to do the same thing
in for instance mcl apply
it's going to be silent if you're in
linux terminal
you're probably going to get some
messages you won't get the warning but
messages and that's just by pure luck
and not by design
so now
2019 the future framework at the core
regardless if you use for each
future apply or fur it will
relay the output and the warnings back
to your main session
and you can use capture output and all
calling handlers and things there
they're relayed back to you in the same
order as
you would expect in sequential
processing
so okay so now this important thing
not i mean feature number one that
everyone asks for
when they do parallel processing i want
progress bars
and why is that because they're probably
running something that takes a long time
and when you spawn it off in parallel
you have no idea what happens
and it's a really hard problem to solve
in a proper way you can do it for
certain things local machine and things
like that but
if you run remote machine or whatever
and the key with the future framework is
you your code should look the same
so i think i solved this so forget about
parallel processing now
if you're just interested in interested
in progress updates you can use this
package
progressor it's on crown since two weeks
ago
it's an inclusive unifying api for
progress updates
it works with all mapreduce things you
want to come up with
and the idea here also is
there's an api for developers and one
for end users
and as a developer the only thing you
should worry about
is how many progress steps you want to
report
on you do that with a function say
progressor
and you create a new function that you
can call and then you call this function
in your thing and every time you call
this function it's going to signal
i made one step and you can send an
optional
message along if you want to the user
has to just decide i want to listen i
want to listen to this i want to get
these updates
or not and they do that with a with
progress function
so they wrap that around where they want
to listen to
so how does this work so another toy
example called snail
this is basically just doing s apply
calling slow function again
on each element of the x vector and
at the end it sums all those results
together and returns
so if the vector x is 50 and slow takes
one minute
it's going to take 50 minutes and it's
going to dead silence here you don't
know if it's running or not
so as a developer you can now just add
these two things
you create a progressor a long x and
then you call this in
every iteration with a message saying
which element you work on
and the user calls it again of course
nothing happens because
they need to do with progress and now
they're listening and they're going to
get progress updates
okay so i mentioned
inclusive i mean inclusive design so not
everyone
would like to see a progress bar in the
terminal someone might want to have
sound feedback so the end user can now
choose to say use the beeper package
so when the thing starts you get one
sound and then you get ticks along the
way
and when it's done it's like catching uh
you can
you can you can combine these you can
do both someone might want to go and
write a
telegram or twitter or email when it's
done or when it starts
so it fits in that model um
[Music]
so it's the end user to decide how it's
reported
this also works with shiny so if you use
the progressor
there's a with progress shiny that you
can use and it will just work with the
shiny
interface okay so now
back to parallel processing
so i both the future framework and the
progressive framework was designed so
they shouldn't know about each other
there's one line of code basically in
future that
knows about progressor i had to do that
but it doesn't depend on the package
it's just the condition class
technically and
this progression updates will work in
parallel
here and to answer the question
that was asked in previous session can
we get more live
updates yes you can that for
certain types of back-ends again your
code doesn't work so this is
a snail example again and the only thing
i changed
i made the supply call using futures
so now if the user want to run it in
parallel and
or remote machines they will run this
thing
so that's in this case the user decided
to run it in parallel on a local machine
and also see progress bars in the
terminal and sound
and this and they will get this and in
the message here i added
what process id was outputting it and as
soon as these are coming in
basically it's through the polling
mechanism but very fast
it will actually get things so progress
come in in a different order
depending on which workers first but we
get it coming in
so this now works since two weeks with
the future framework
i one thing before i got to my last
slide
there is a big hope and chance that in
our 4.0 that comes in now in the spring
global calling handlers will be
available and that basically means
in this case we don't need to use that
with progress so the end user
just called the function so that's a
cleaner interface
and there are other use cases for global
hunters that's really keen on but
okay so take a message
try it as a developer focus on what to
paralyze
not how that's the user's decision stay
with your favorite coding style
and it's auto magic as we said like for
each global packages output warnings
errors and progress bars
are handled thank you
[Applause]
uh so we have time for a couple
questions um so the first one here what
is the communication overhead between
processes and then i would kind of add
on top of that
like when you have large data sets
like when you're transferring them
between processes what are your what's
your advice there
yeah so two things here
parallel processing in r at this level
not like native code
multi-threading stuff is more of things
that takes
several seconds to run you don't do
super small things and typically if you
get things running for like a whole
minute that's very very you don't have
to worry about the overhead
there's so that's the orchestration over
it you have
overhead from passing data too
and there are things in the fur package
in the future apply that try to do this
in a clever way
so you don't send out everything that
you need but you need to transfer data
if you have big data
so of course if you send that to mars or
whatever
that will be take a long time so you
have to think about that and that's the
corner case this is like
is this should the data live locally or
should it be distributed
so for web scraping and web api data is
it better to run code in parallel or
maybe asynchronously like using the
later package for example
whoa that's out of my league is that the
expression in english
um but i think yeah i think you can use
the later package you can use this
in combined you can use later and use
multiple things in parallel for you
later
so you kind of spoke on this a little
bit but how does future parallelize on
local machines does it fork our
processes like parallel or like what
does it do on windows
yeah so that's a good question so i i
didn't have to go for i have time to go
through all details
future package doesn't really do the
back ends it's just leveraging
the parallel package so you have the
option to use multi-core forking like
mcl apply
or the cluster but these also allow you
to do other things
so there's like a caller package there's
a caller back end so
the future package try to stay away from
that but it comes with a parallel
package
built in yeah perfect thank you so much
thank you very much
you